[Música]
Hola son muchos los acontecimientos que
tienen lugar en una semana en el mundo
pero en este espacio de France 24
analizamos y conversamos sobre los temas
más destacados en los últimos cinco días
bienvenidos esto es una semana en el
mundo para conversar sobre este tema o
los temas que tenemos para este programa
saludamos a Cecilia Valenzuela ella es
periodista y directora del diario pero
21 ya se encuentra en la Ciudad de Lima
Cecilia Bienvenida al programa y cómo
termina su semana
Hola cómo estás Santiago bueno esta
semana ha sido una semana realmente
yo diría que
caótica para el Perú es una semana en la
que los peruanos nos damos cuenta que
estamos viviendo no solamente una crisis
política y económica sino también moral
la fiscalía de la nación que es la más
la máxima autoridad de de carácter
investigativo desde la justicia en el
Perú
planteó una denuncia presentó una
denuncia constitucional al congreso de
la República pidiéndole al congreso que
suspenda en sus actividades al
presidente de la república que es Pedro
Castillo por dos causas penales muy
contundentes y cargada de pruebas claro
tema que le estamos poniendo la lupa
también y tenemos en el rodar para ir
analizando aquí en los diferentes
programas de France 24 también saludo a
Sofía barruti ella es periodista y
columnista de temas internacionales para
diferentes medios argentinos algunos de
ellos en televisión otros en radio Sofía
Bienvenida al programa y cómo termina
usted su semana
qué tal Santiago Cómo te va bueno Bien
también poniendo de foco lo que sucede
en Rusia lo que sucede en Estados Unidos
hay muchos temas en la agenda
internacional y la verdad que a esta
altura con la pandemia y con la guerra
uno no puede decir que todas las
realidades que suceden en el mundo y les
son ajenas también
sí Sofía vamos a mejorar la conexión con
Sofía para para poder tener una buena
conexión para poder entender lo que nos
está diciendo y desarrollar el programa
sin problema sin ningún problema técnico
Mientras tanto continuamos aquí con
nuestros invitados aquí en el estudio de
France 24 está con nosotros Johana
galvis Castro ella es periodista
majester en relaciones internacionales
ese editor Internacional del servicio
informativo de Blu radio en Colombia
Johana bienvenida un gusto tenerla aquí
en el programa y Cómo terminó hasta su
semana no pues Santiago un placer
También poder participar en este
programa donde precisamente vamos a
analizar esa semana tan tribulada que
hemos vivido los periodistas
internacionales con la guerra en Ucrania
y otros temas muchos temas tenemos para
analizar Solamente vamos a analizar
cuatro de ellos lo más importante los
que hemos escogido para este programa
ustedes también nos pueden acompañar con
todas sus opiniones el comentario y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
recuerde estamos como arroba
france24_es@santilo en mi cuenta
personal y nuestra etiqueta es numeral
una semana en el mundo f24 dejen todos
sus comentarios y preguntas allí Pues
muy bien Vamos entonces con el primer
tema porque esta semana tal vez estuvo
marcada por los hechos en Ucrania la
ofensiva o Muchos medios también han
titulado como la revancha por parte de
Rusia con bombardeos y ataques que
dejaron zonas residenciales e
infraestructuras afectadas en diferentes
ciudades de Ucrania eso llamó la
atención de prácticamente todos los
medios internacionales los bombardeos
llegaron incluso hasta la ciudad de kiev
la capital de ese país que hasta ahora
en cierta forma estaba protegida de los
ataques rusos el presidente ucraniano
bolo de merceleski hizo un llamado a la
comunidad internacional para que ayuden
a este país para mejorar su sistema de
defensa anti a ella quien lo podrá
ayudar la respuesta vino por parte de la
otan por supuesto y también directamente
de algunos países europeos como Alemania
y Francia mientras en el kremlin en
Moscú el subsecretario del Consejo de
Seguridad de la federación rusa
Alexander benedictof dijo que la entrada
de Ucrania o la posible entrada de
Ucrania la otan podría provocar una
tercera guerra mundial por supuesto
todos los medios de comunicación
titularon esa frase sobre esa posible
ese posible conflicto a gran escala que
podría desarrollarse con Rusia comienza
entonces aquí en el estudio de France 24
con Johana para preguntarle vamos a
tener una tercera guerra mundial usted
teme a las amenazas Y a lo que dice el
kremlin yo creo Santiago que durante el
desarrollo de esta guerra que comienza
en febrero de
2022 del 24 de febrero nos hemos
preguntado muchas veces lo mismo tercera
guerra mundial cuando arranca tercera
guerra mundial a los cinco meses Ahorita
estamos viendo un remonte de los ataques
por parte de el ejército ruso sobre los
territorios ucranianos cada uno tiene
una posición algunos avanzan otros
retroceden cada uno tiene un discurso y
estamos ante un relanzamiento de la
guerra pero todavía se le está dando
chance a las actividades diplomáticas
tanto de Estados Unidos como los
miembros de la otan y de la Unión
Europea
intentando saber qué hacer entonces
vemos un discurso de Putin Y de nuevo
Estados Unidos enviando armas y de nuevo
selenski pidiendo ayuda pidiendo ese
grito desesperado de no me dejen solo
aquí esta gente se me está metiendo pero
la tercera guerra mundial yo no creería
que podamos hablar de eso todavía yo
creo que todavía tenemos que darle un
chance al desarrollo del conflicto
porque de nuevo estamos viendo los
discursos de febrero claro los discursos
de hace unos meses vamos a ver qué forma
va a tomar esta esta guerra y también
hay que creerle mucho a lo que dice
bailen porque a veces con la falta de
credibilidad que algunos
sectores en Estados Unidos le están
quitando sobre sus posiciones frente a
algunos temas internacionales como la
guerra Entonces no le creen Pero él dijo
y adelantó muchas veces lo que iba a
pasar en Ucrania y nadie le dio tanto
crédito hasta que no se disparó la
primera bala no se estalló la primera
bomba entonces también hay que creer lo
que está diciendo vayan lo que está
diciendo el pentágono Ellos tienen
información que claramente el mundo no
conoce solamente Ellos saben que lo que
está sucediendo en ese punto del planeta
pues hay que tenerlo en cuenta sobre
todo cuando bailes necesita también
ganar puntos porque está próximo a las
elecciones de medio término
la palabra a Cecilia en la Ciudad de
Lima Cecilia como lo vio usted qué
análisis se puede hacer de los hechos de
esta semana hasta remontada de los
ataques por parte de Rusia y este
discurso simplemente un discurso
guerrerista digámoslo así bélico por
parte del kremlin para mantener la
atención el miedo como lo analiza usted
bueno en las declaraciones recientes del
gobierno ruso claramente
terminan por preocuparnos no es cierto
esta mañana pues por supuesto el horario
en Europa es distinto
ya han hablado de alrededor de 222.000
este soldados nuevos reservistas
alistados para continuar el conflicto
entonces realmente uno piensa que este
conflicto está escalando claro la bomba
en el puente ese puente de crimea que ha
sido que ha herido tremendamente el
orgullo de Putin yo creo que determina
una situación este muy muy grave para el
propio gobierno ruso actual por otro
lado sabemos que en Rusia también hay
gente que es mucho más extremista que el
propio Putin y que le está este le está
reclamando que sea más agresivo Y claro
hay también otras personas como los que
hemos visto es huir salir de su país
este muchos jóvenes
por supuesto es la posición este en
contra Pero esto está escalando y a mí
sí me parece muy preocupante Sí y Sofía
Cuál es su opinión para cerrar esta esta
primera ronda de preguntas
están escalándose el conflicto Es
simplemente parte del discurso o hay que
tener una preocupación por esta esta
amenaza por parte de Moscú
Sí Santiago yo creo que en las últimas
horas Vladimir Putin habló sobre este
tema y dijo que tiene intención de
ponerle el fin a los ataques masivos
pero lamentablemente permitíme pensar
que esto no es más que volver a
movilizarse y yo no puedo creer a esta
altura del partido en la inocencia de
Vladimir Putin pero también hay que
hablar de que aquellos nexos
diplomáticos mismo la figura de Manuel
macrón intentando de alguna manera
mediar en este conflicto han fracasado
por lo menos en esta etapa de la guerra
no una guerra que parece que la hemos
leído en los libros de historia Y
lamentablemente estamos volviendo a
repetir con lo que sucedió en el puente
que uner a Rusia con crimea como foco de
este conflicto pero también hay que
decir que en esta guerra nos están
librando únicamente vidas de militares
sino también de civiles Y
lamentablemente eso sucede desde febrero
a esta parte Así que no hay que perderlo
de foco no hay que perder de este que en
esta en esta guerra se están perdiendo
muchas pero muchas vidas Y pareciera que
con la movilización de todos estos
reservistas la La Apuesta de Vladimir
Putin está subiendo lejos de bajar y
lejos de encontrar una solución a esta
guerra que tiene coletazos para la vida
de la gente y también el coletazo
económico para todo un mundo que está al
intemperie podríamos decir con
inflaciones históricas en todo el mundo
para agregar a lo que dicen las colegas
es muy importante lo que plantean
ahorita sobre las pérdidas civiles sobre
el tema económico y también sobre el
liderazgo que se ha desdibujado en
Europa los líderes europeos han tomado
como caballito de batalla lo que está
pasando en Ucrania pero no han sido no
han logrado ser efectivos a través de la
ofensiva diplomática y sobre ese tema
también cada uno ha tomado discursos que
hay que analizar con cuidado Putin al
comienzo decía nosotros nos vamos a
meter yo no voy a armar una guerra yo no
estoy haciendo nada y dio el golpe
ahorita está diciendo No yo no quiero
escalar esto a ninguna otra nivel de
agresión no sabemos qué va a pasar
entonces mientras podemos creerle a unos
también hay que tener mucho cuidado con
lo que dice Putin y leer entre líneas
ese no se puede convertir en un sí a
medida que va pasando el conflicto y la
lectura que se hace de la destrucción
del puente de crimea tiene algo muy
grande desde el lado de Ucrania y la
forma en la que se informa en la que
ellos también lo informan que es usando
ese vídeo de Marilyn Monroe cantándole
el cumpleaños hay un jefe Kennedy de una
forma muy irónica diciéndoles Aquí vamos
a seguir y ellos han dicho nuestros los
ucranianos han dicho nuestros ciudadanos
han vuelto porque saben que vamos a
ganar la guerra mientras en Rusia
algunos dicen no yo no voy a la guerra
pero es un discurso de lado y lado que
hay que verlos y escucharlos desde la
población civil hasta desde hasta los
políticos con mucho porque eso nos va a
decir qué tanto va a durar este
conflicto y tiene una visión a largo
plazo Esto no se va a acabar mañana
en algunos momentos y se está
prolongando en el tiempo y lo que usted
dice hay que tener mucho cuidado sobre
todo en esos discursos de propaganda
sabemos la estructura propaganda que
tiene Rusia pero Ucrania también por la
guerra ha sabido manejar muy bien el
sistema de propaganda a su favor y ha
logrado que la comunidad internacional
pues se ponga prácticamente del lado de
ellos de ustedes estaban viendo algunas
de las imágenes mientras ustedes
intervenían mientras las invitadas
intervenían veíamos las imágenes de la
destrucción de los edificios la mayoría
de los sitios que fueron bombardeados a
lo largo de esta semana en ciudades como
zaporilla o como kiev eran son las
residenciales muchos dicen que ya
definitivamente el presidente Putin pues
ya perdió el miedo por completo porque
inicialmente los ataques eran a
infraestructura puntual para la guerra
pero ya vemos que cada vez más se avanza
a atacar a los ciudadanos Cecilia esto
le juega en contra al presidente Putin
esto empieza a generar otras alertas a
nivel de Derechos Humanos crímenes de
guerra que puede hacer la comunidad
internacional ahí uno eso ese tema Cómo
se puede empezar a tocar
Bueno la verdad es que útil le juega
todo en contra no porque quien ha
comenzado y queda en esta en evidencia
está así en esta de esta situación es él
Entonces yo creo que él está muy gastado
que eso también es un elemento
interesante para el análisis
muy gastado al interior de su país
porque hay quienes le reclaman este
desde lado más extremo y también en el
entre los líderes europeos
evidentemente la comunidad internacional
tiene que seguir presionando no se puede
quedar la comunidad internacional no nos
podemos quedar los demás viendo cómo se
masacra civiles y los ucranianos han
denunciado una serie de masacres de ese
tipo y son ciertas Entonces es
fundamental la presión porque de otra
manera este conflicto que tiene mucho
que ver también con el ego del su propio
líder ruso este
no va a terminar Entonces yo creo que
tiene que seguir existiendo una presión
ha sido muy interesante para mí ver
recientemente en Europa en por ejemplo
dos edificios con
pancartas Dios no reclamando y todos en
contra de la invasión de Rusia a Ucrania
claro esa sociedad que protesta no puede
dejar de hacerlo Sofía para terminar
este tema de los bombardeos en ciudades
como kiefisa por ella cree que a los
medios de comunicación nos ha faltado un
poco más de tacto digámoslo así para
manejar este tema donde ya hay tantas
víctimas civiles donde se está atacando
estas zonas residenciales le estamos
dando más importancia al tema político
al discurso de Putin a lo que responde
la otan y nos estamos olvidando un poco
de ese lado humano el drama que están
viviendo los ucranianos
qué buena pregunta es Santiago y yo le
sumo al drama que están viviendo los
ucranianos el drama que también está
viviendo la sociedad Rusia rusa no con
el tema de la movilización de los
reservistas que también ha ocasionado
muchos problemas migratorios de mucha
gente que no está de acuerdo con el
gobierno de Vladimir Putin y quiera
abandonar su su propio país Yo creo que
la sensibilidad Se ha perdido en el
momento en el que sea masificado tanto
la muerte no Porque empezamos a hablar
de un civil muerto de dos civiles
muertos y después terminamos hablando de
incontables pérdidas humanas
Lamentablemente y yo creo que uno de los
principales errores que tuvimos los
medios de comunicación más allá de Sí
por supuesto poner porque esta guerra es
creo que una de las más politizadas del
último tiempo creo que que lo que
fallamos como como medios en algún
momento fue en dejar de poner en agenda
el drama de los refugiados de los
fallecidos por supuesto en primera
medida y también de lo que sucede con
una sociedad rusa ha quedado devastada
que está en comunicada que si no se les
permite tampoco comunicarse que cada vez
está más acotados en cuanto a los medios
que tienen para hacerlo los medios
estatales rusos Son los únicos que
pueden consumir Entonces tenemos que
hablar también de la gente en Rusia que
no está de acuerdo que se está tratando
de ir y lamentablemente no pueden con
este último llamado la movilización de
reservista Santiago Este es un conflicto
que afecta a dos lados dos lados de la
frontera para ir cerrando Yohana este
tema de de Rusia veíamos ese llamado que
hacía el presidente de selensky por más
ayuda internacional para pedir fondos
para mejorar su sistema antiaéreo Sí hay
mucha ayuda hay muchos países dispuestos
a ayudarlos hasta el final del conflicto
pero pero tampoco esto es un cheque en
blanco y menos cuando estamos a punto de
entrar en una recesión en algunos países
o por lo menos a profundizarse los
problemas económicos qué tanto más
podemos la comunidad internacional
ayudar a Ucrania a nivel económico tanto
más el mundo puede estar del lado de
ellos Aunque Santiago no sabemos cuánto
va a durar el conflicto creo que es
momento de comenzar a mirar qué va a
pasar cuando este se acabe Y eso ahí
entra el tema económico ahí entran Esas
cuentas pendientes de yo te ayude lo que
le quedo debiendo a los que me ayudaron
y cómo vamos también a atender a esa
población civil que tuvo que emigrar
porque es una migración en esta época en
la que pese a que hemos visto muchos
movimientos humanos durante muchos años
esta guerra es particular y esta
migración es particular porque estamos
aprendiendo de nuevo a manejar este tipo
de situaciones eso es una guerra nueva
para todos Hasta en lo diplomáticos
están aprendiendo hasta en las
relaciones internacionales están
reprendiendo y se están cuestionando
algunos mecanismos que se supone que
deberían ser efectivos en este momento
para atender lo que está pasando
Entonces es guerra en la que estamos
aprendiendo es una guerra en la que ya
tenemos que pensar en qué vamos a hacer
después de que esto se acabe no tenemos
que esperar acá y se acabe para decir
bueno Y ahora que vamos a hacer creo que
es un momento en el que también Tenemos
que irnos hacia la reflexión de cómo se
va a ayudar a los ucranianos también hay
aquellos rusos que dijeron No y que de
qué forma los vamos a rodear para esa
recuperación tanto a nivel social y con
y económica Bueno pues Les propongo que
dejemos este tema y avancemos con otro
de los hechos importantes de la semana
también fue importante lo que pasó en
Washington y pasaron allí muchos
acontecimientos a lo largo de la semana
por ejemplo la comisión que Investiga
los hechos ocurridos en el Capitolio del
6 de enero del 2021 esta semana fue dado
a conocer varios vídeos donde se ven los
senadores tanto republicanos como
demócratas al interior del Capitolio
hablando por teléfono muy preocupados
por la situación reclamandole al
entonces presidente Donald Trump por el
manejo que le estaba dando a la
situación justamente el comité que
Investiga este asalto lo llamó para
testificar Trump anunció que dará una
respuesta a este comité y también
reiteró su idea de un presunto fraude
electoral en las elecciones
presidenciales y llamó a los políticos
de su país
corruptos y mafiosos comienzo Entonces
por Sofía cree usted Sofía que entonces
Trump se iba a asistir a a esta
audiencia vamos a ver a Trump sentado en
esta audiencia en el Capitolio
respondiendo las preguntas de la
comisión
Permítame dudarlo Santiago la verdad que
no lo creo a todos Nos gustaría porque
realmente lo que lo que ha sucedido
también en el Capitolio se llevó vidas
también hubo cinco personas que
fallecieron y y la comisión o por lo
menos la investigación que se está
llevando en este momento
comprobar que efectivamente Esto fue
orquestado que estuvo orquestado mismo
yo me acuerdo mucho de ese momento de
seguirme en minuto a minuto las redes
sociales En ese sentido nos han hecho
sentir como si estuviéramos ahí no y
Donald Trump en ningún momento se se
arrepintió Y pareciera ser que incluso
les lo felicitaba de alguna manera les
decía ya han hecho demasiado váyanse a
descansar no Entonces yo creo que que
esa actitud de Trump hasta el día de hoy
él no no la ha cambiado Lamentablemente
estamos en un momento muy importante a
nivel mundial y también para Estados
Unidos Ya falta nada para las elecciones
de medio término y también para el 2024
Y pareciera ser que lejos de esta grie
como le decimos aquí los argentinos
entre republicanos y demócratas parece
que se asiente un poco más así que
respondiendo un poco a su pregunta
inicial no creo que lo veamos a Donald
Trump pese a la citación que en este
momento se está llevando a cabo Cecilia
también conversando aquí con varios
colegas de France 24 en la redacción
sobre este tema muchos se preguntaban
Pero por qué justo ahora llaman al
expresidente a dar una declaración
cuando esta investigación ya viene desde
hace varios meses tendrás tú algo que
ver con
lo que menciona Sofía que estamos
próximos a las elecciones de medio
término hay algo ahí de Conspiración
como lo vio usted bueno la política
siempre tiene algo de Conspiración no y
evidentemente
algo que ver con la política y con esa
política conspirativa el propio Trump
trazó porque cuando él Él lleva a la
gente a invadir el Capitolio lo que en
realidad está cumpliendo es un plan que
ya lo tenía determinado él se quería
proclamar presidente como fuera y ya
había tramado este tipo de acción de
hecho esa esto es uno de los resultados
una de las convicciones que han tenido
los integrantes de la comisión
investigadora no olvidemos que los votos
han sido por unanimidad o sea los nueve
integrantes votaron a favor de citar a
trabajo yo comparto la idea de que Trump
no va a ir este Pero bueno también
podría ir y organizar un show este como
está acostumbrado a hacerlo Yo creo que
un personaje como trampa desnaturalizado
de una manera brutal la el manejo de la
política en los Estados Unidos
después la política de Estados Unidos
antes y después del gobierno Giovanna
aquí en el estudio de France 24 esto que
repercusiones puede tener para esas
elecciones de medio término me imagino
que usted como periodista internacional
usted está contando los días para el
recubrimiento porque son unas elecciones
que están generando muchísima atención
Santiago ahí se van a definir muchas
cosas en especial para el gobierno
actual va a ser un voto castigo o un
voto respaldo para vaiden va a ser un
análisis de cómo ha vivido Estados
Unidos esa administración de Joe biden Y
lo que pase con Trump en el comité yo me
uno a esa teoría que no va pero le dejó
un 50% a que de pronto si va a hacer su
show hacer su show y asentarse a a citar
La Quinta enmienda y a decir su propia
Verdad que es la propia verdad que envió
en una carta de 14 páginas al comité
diciendo no es que reiterando el
discurso del robo de las elecciones
Entonces eso nos puede abrir una de los
dos escenarios o no va y se enfrenta un
escenario legal porque eso no asistencia
de su hogar representar un escenario
legal y se va a dar esa pelea porque él
se ha dado muchas peleas de ese estilo Y
no le da miedo pero sí va va a decir su
propia verdad que en esa carta como
dejaba ver porque no me han llamado
antes sí sí han hablado tanto de mí
porque no me han llamado antes entonces
están esos dos escenarios sobre las
Mister biden se la está jugando toda
porque ahí se van a definir las fuerzas
que lo van a seguir acompañando en este
gobierno y cómo va a enfrentar esa
posible reelección con la que coquetea
deja de coquetear dice que sí después no
sé
Cómo va a enfrentar ese nuevo proceso el
voto se va a el voto que se va a emitir
ese en esa época va a ser algo
definitivo para ese apoyo que se ha
venido desde dibujando Y esa falta de
credibilidad que le han ido quitando
algunos sectores en la Unión Americana
Pues creo que entonces hay consenso
entre ustedes tres que el presidente el
ex presidente Trump no va a asistir a
esta comisión Pero bueno dejamos este
tema abierto para ver qué puede suceder
en los próximos días yo Les propongo que
nos movamos hacia el siguiente tema que
tenemos destacado de la semana
Aprovechando que el panel de hoy está
compuesto por primera por mujeres de
primerísimo nivel como periodista así
como mujeres Pues esta semana también se
cumple un mes de la detención y de la
muerte de la joven iraní maxa amini
quien fue arrestada por la policía de la
moral por no llevar correctamente el
velo islámico su muerte estando bajo
custodia policial ha desatado una serie
de manifestaciones que lo hemos
reportado aquí en France 24
manifestaciones
antecedentes en Irán manifestaciones a
las que también se han Unido algunos
sectores de la sociedad para protestar
Aprovechando que están allí en las
calles también por las condiciones
económicas y para reclamar más derechos
y libertades el gobierno iraní Sin dar
mucha muestra de querer Escuchar al
pueblo y tal vez de conciliar ha
respondido con represión más de un
centenar de personas han fallecido en
estas manifestaciones han cortado el
servicio de internet y sobre todo ha
habido mucha represión en la región del
kurdistán iraní comienzo con Cecilia
preguntándole desde su punto de vista
como mujer como periodista las mujeres
iraníes están llevando al país a un
punto de quiebre en la historia de este
país y de la Revolución islámica como lo
ve usted
realmente ha sido
conmovedor ver este a estas mujeres
actuando yo las admiro profundamente no
puedo dejar de tener en cuenta que
pasaron demasiados años demasiados años
desde que fueron nuevamente su juzgadas
este hasta en la época del ya de Irán
verdad
eran iguales están las mujeres y los
hombres accedían a los estudios se
informaban Y por supuesto se vestían
como les parecía conveniente vestirse y
luego con la llegada del aire atola pues
todo se va para atrás y son Realmente
tratadas como ciudadanos de segunda
categoría esto ha tomado muchos años
pero ha llegado el momento en el que
ellas han protestado y es impresionante
como han logrado salir crear
cascos a pesar de que no estaban
permitidas varias generaciones de
mujeres este de participar en
actividades movilizaciones activismo y
los jóvenes están siguiéndolas el hackeo
que hicieron jóvenes protestantes la
semana terminando la semana anterior el
sábado anterior de la televisión
que ha llevado al gobierno a bloquear
por supuesto todas las las posibilidades
de acceso a la internet fue algo
importante fue una muestra de
solidaridad total y yo creo que esto ya
no tiene retorno y y las mujeres dirán
van a lograr salir adelante y enseñarnos
muchísimo a las mujeres del mundo entero
Lo que sí es cierto le va a dar la
palabra a Johana ya le doy la palabra
Sofía en unos minutos lo que sí es
cierto es que ha habido una gran
solidaridad a nivel internacional no
solamente de mujeres iraníes que viven
en el sino de mujeres de otros países
que simplemente
ven identificadas su realidad con las
mujeres iraníes o simplemente quieren
Mostrar apoyo también el cubrimiento en
los medios está el mundo occidental
dándole demasiada despliegue este tema
aprovechando esta debilidad del gobierno
iraní o se le está dando de verdad la
importancia a la mujer iraní aquí hay
varias cosas que hay que tener en cuenta
lo que decía nuestra colega desde Perú
desde el 79 desde este desde esta
llegada de la Revolución islámica hay
una asignatura pendiente con las mujeres
en Irán Y esa asignatura pendiente ha
tenido diferentes capítulos lo que pasó
con marcha Minnie es un nombre de muchos
que desde hace varios años recuerdo
muertes en el 2007 2009 en las protestas
muertes de mujeres que se han dado en
espacios públicos espacios públicos
donde ellas marchan donde ellas intentan
alzar su voz donde ellas dicen no
portando el velo o hasta haciendo un tik
Tok o grabando lo que está pasando en la
ciudad
Irán ha tenido una apertura en ciertos
temas una tímida apertura en ciertos
temas desde 2017 entre más económicos un
poco en tema político pero este gobierno
con este ultraconservador el presidente
que está actualmente
marca
como esa Dinamita que necesitan las
mujeres en Irán para decir no más Y es
que hemos visto como desde los colegios
rompen las figuras del ayatolá de los
líderes de la Revolución como esa voz se
ha escuchado un poco más de las muertes
anteriores o sea Masha fue es ahorita el
ingrediente para poder hablar y decir no
más el apoyo que le genere occidente
Esto no se puede volver paisaje no se
puede volver una tendencia más de
internet donde todas nos cortamos el
pelo sino que se vean cosas que están
funcionando y que se pongan en marcha no
tiene que ser más allá de una tendencia
sino cosas que puedan realizarse en la
política iraní tímidamente también hay
una participación femenina muy pequeña
pero están presentes ahí de ahí hay que
agarrarse también esa comunidad debería
agarrarse claro las manifestaciones es
una forma de manifestar claramente ese
descontento pero hay que ir más allá y
si occidente quiere involucrarse tiene
que pararse de una forma más certera Lo
cierto es que Tal parece que las mujeres
han perdido el miedo a general y salen a
las calles a manifestarse Sofía para
cerrar este tema lo que quiera
comentar sobre el tema puntual de de
esta joven iraní y también le le
pregunto es increíble que en el 2022
todavía tengamos que ver a las mujeres
en las calles reivindicando derechos
pidiendo libertades cuando ya deberíamos
de estar en un equilibrio en un balance
a nivel social a todo nivel Y todavía
seguimos viendo esto
a mí Santiago verdaderamente lo que veo
en las calles de Irán que tampoco se
puede estar cubriendo por medios
occidentales porque hay una Clara
censura pese a todo esto a mí lo que me
emociona es la fuerza y le interesa de
esas mujeres y de esos hombres que
también salieron a manifestarse porque
han sido apoyados por por varios hombres
también pero concretamente me quiero
detener en las mujeres de la generación
Z no nosotros probablemente ninguno de
nosotros pertenezca a Esta generación
pero pero sin embargo esto muestra un
poco y la generación sin miedo la
generación que sale en contra de todas
las personas que estén reprimiendo los
censurándolos yo creo que esto a pesar
de ser una tragedia lo que se está
viviendo en Irán no solamente con esta
joven de 22 años Lamentablemente y aquí
coincido con con mis colegas sino
también un siembra una esperanza y un
Halo de luz frente a tanta oscuridad no
con una generación que no ya que sale a
manifestarse y que se plantea de Cara a
un futuro porque tienen que que vivirse
estas realidades no también es una tarea
que tenemos que pensar y no sé si
ustedes coincidirán conmigo de cara al
mundial que
captar no donde también hay muchas
libertades de las mujeres que están
viéndose cercenadas también de la
comunidad lgtbi van a tener que
replantearse ciertas ciertas cuestiones
y ciertos modelos por supuesto
respetando la religiosidad pero no que
por eso se cercenen las libertades y los
derechos y más que nada sobre todo que
no se pierda ningún tipo de vida al
Siglo 21 parece absurdo tener que estar
hablando de esto
Qatar va a ser un buen ensayo para ver
cómo se puede manejar esta situación nos
quedan ya un par de minutos para
finalizar el programa quiero
preguntarles rápidamente por el 12 de
octubre el día de la raza o de
resistencia indígena O el día del
descubrimiento de América de la
diversidad cultural rápidamente Qué
opinión tienen ustedes de este día que
genera tanta controversia y desde qué
punto de deberíamos ver Johana desde el
punto de vista histórico desde el punto
de vista del legado cultural o desde qué
lado usted lo aborda usted como
periodista y como mujer podría abordarse
desde una
sanación
cultural
ya dejar de lado los odios que hemos
arrastrado por años pero hacer esa
transición una sanación cultural que
pueda transicionar para poder seguir
adelante porque en un año de nuevo vamos
a recordar lo doloroso de nuevo vamos a
recordar esos momentos oscuros y es
momento de
considero yo como de resignificar ese
día y Cecilia su opinión
Bueno yo creo que somos mestizos en
América Latina por lo menos
es de ese mestizaje tenemos que rescatar
lo mejor y como dice mi colega que está
contigo en el en el set Santiago es hora
de pasar esa página y ir hacia adelante
apreciar lo que hemos heredado de uno y
de otro lado
entender que esta mixtura nos enriquece
y no nos arrincona y salir adelante Eso
es así es como yo lo veo y Sofía su su
conclusión sobre este tema rápidamente
Sí yo creo que que hay que repensar todo
lo que tiene que ver con el
reconocimiento de los pueblos
originarios Santiago aquí en la
República Argentina y también en Chile
estamos muy preocupados por lo que está
sucediendo con alguna facciones de los
pueblos mapuches que se están en este
momento revelando de alguna manera y
están siendo muy pero muy violentos Pero
no por ello hay que englobar a toda la
comunidad mapuche o todos los pueblos
originarios en lo mismo hay mucha tela
para cortar en este tema y hay mucha
tarea que hacer para que los pueblos
originarios sean reconocidos y que
también no reneguemos tanto de nuestra
historia que nos ha traído hasta aquí
hasta donde estamos hoy isanar como
sociedad latinoamérica tiene que sanar
ese punto y un poco trascender me quedan
ya segundos para terminar el programa
rápidamente les pregunto a cada una qué
tema Tienen en la lupa para la siguiente
semana en sus redacciones o en sus
investigaciones o en sus artículos en lo
que vayan a desarrollar comienzo con
Sofía qué tema va a tener ahí en la lupa
bueno la colega lo decía al principio no
lo que tiene que ver con Perú y la falta
disyuncionalidad o la crisis política
Mejor dicho nos repercute aquí en la
República Argentina como como hermandad
que tenemos en América Latina y por
supuesto también lo que sucede entre
Lula y Jair bolsonaro en Brasil una
campaña realmente muy pero muy reñida y
también violenta no la violencia
política y demasiado Santiago
rápidamente que ya no tengo tiempo
puntual
Perú Perú y Brasil exactamente coincido
la situación en Perú
Pero y Brasil indiscutiblemente nuestra
región pues ustedes Muchísimas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros es todo
por el programa de hoy Les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros la producción
estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera Muchas gracias sigan
con Franz 24
[Música]